can I tell you where where I was mad at
you don't want only time I was mad at
you I went to don't know we were in loo
no no we were in Shreveport Louisiana
are you allergic to cats
okay yes the best we were in Shreveport
- whatever having a [ __ ] Tamayo bro
just talking using the jungles of Hawaii
that she was eating cat she eats cats
and she she built a little house in the
jungles of Hawaii
she's the last time I saw for sure
because two years ago three years ago I
saw her at the store right she got
because I stood when I first started I
did shows with her so we're friends
right and she goes look at this is the
house I built right and she goes I eat
cats she hunts cats there are a lot of
stray cats in Hawaii yes maybe but I am
like oh how was your trip to Hawaii
it was great it was good it's working
for him it was really really good work
for you you know the she know what women
do I like to go out and do things and he
leaves in the morning we got to get up
and go on a boat to swim with sharks
that's not his thing that is not a
vacation that's me being a Navy SEAL
the job its job okay I want to relax
I know how you vacation what why can't
you guys do a happy medium um I don't
know how you find a happy medium when I
want to swim with sharks well I did
there were a happy medium was you just
got on the boat and didn't swim with the
sharks but then you could you you didn't
want three girls to out you know were
the three girls oh really
yeah but can I did go back to the
Shreveport Louisiana yes you were seeing
this girl she was like 18 this was so
bad dude how how is she I don't I hated
her I remember she said some racist yes
not only that I walked into the green
room we were on stage yeah and she had
my wallet in her hand
looking through it Wow my god and I
taught then I told you about it like
this [ __ ] try to steal money from me so
then the whole weekend we I had to hang
out with this [ __ ] yeah I mean Tomika
think chinese racist [ __ ] and i'm like
this guy he's my boss but he would think
that he did not defend me because of her
titties i mean i may give it to defend
him she was really hot but she was a
[ __ ] creature yeah for sure
super a super racist yeah yeah yeah she
like never seen anyone like you before
yeah I know I know
yeah yeah she's a young girl she's
really a bartender so I know but still I
mean it's less offend me you didn't have
money was like yen or some [ __ ] yeah but
I remember that so that I was really mad
about that you know but other than that
I think that's it
[Music]